the first step in understanding how
nature works is understanding the world
of insects as 21 year old Ricardo Goethe
from Mozambique has already learned he's
a trainee in the garland Gaza national
park with this oh this insect belongs to
the beetle family a ground beetle family
Ricardo is helping piatra not scratchy
from Harvard University compile a
biodiversity database the scientist is
working on collecting and recording
information on the species of the
region's ok we have crickets this will
help park managers understand and
protect gorongosa's biodiversity usually
has some black markings on the legs only
about ten percent of insect species are
known to man not much considering the
crucial role they play in the food chain
they provide a number of services
without which we wouldn't be able to
function so things like pollination you
know all these moths without them all
the trees and plants without around us
wouldn't be able to produce fruit locals
are benefitting from this research the
park provides them with an income by
creating work opportunities laboratories
and tourist bungalows are under
construction and there's a growing
demand for safari guides and park
rangers poaching is becoming less common
place in the 1980s Gorongosa Park fell
victim to the civil war in Mozambique
and much of its wildlife was wiped out
these days elephants lions and antelope
are starting to return but many problems
remain the rainforest has been partly
cleared the timber shipped off abroad
mainly to China locals still use wood
fuel
to cook including in Ricardo's village
electricity is prohibitively expensive
creo que de quel Guzan I think we're
running the risk of losing our
biodiversity there's too much
deforestation going on no star fish
potatoes and magical avisan the idea is
that the young trainees who work in the
park will put their experience to good
use in their villages they're learning
the importance of preserving all aspects
of biodiversity however small even bats
many of them more than 1,000 species
native to Gorongosa Park are rare armed
with his net Ricardo is helping science
learn more about them thereby
contributing to the restoration effort
to reverse biodiversity losses